bonsoir pourtant présent merci d'être
avec nous une rencontre donc entre savez
sergueï lavrov et john kerry à moscou
après donc le sommet à genève du 16 mai
entre l'émir poutine et joe biden est ce
qu'on peut y voir un réchauffement
diplomatique entre les deux pays
oui bien sûr on peut y voir un
réchauffement diplomatique entre les
deux pays et je crois que d'ailleurs
cette visite constitue la meilleure
démonstration de la méthode sur laquelle
les deux présidents le président
bayonnais le président poutine se sont
mis d'accord à genève à savoir
identifier des sujets prévus si possible
des sujets concrets sur lesquels il ya
un intérêt commun des deux parties et
sur lesquels on doit faire des progrès
sur lesquels on peut faire des progrès
et ses progrès n'étant pas du tout
conditionné par les sujets sur lesquels
on reste en désaccord
autrement dit on peut discuter du
réchauffement climatique mais à genève
on a dit aussi qu'on pouvait discuter du
contrôle des armements
on a dit aussi qu'on veut discuter de
cyber sécurité
même si on n'est pas d'accord sur les
droits de l'homme ou sur d'autres sujets
qui touchent par exemple à l'ukraine
cette méthode est donc maintenant en
application et ce n'est pas par hasard
que on a choisi le réchauffement
climatique pour la mettre en marche
parce que il ya une urgence comme les
deux ministres viennent de le dire
l'urgence c'est qu'il y à une coop 26 à
glasgow
au début du mois de novembre et que
cette coop 26
il faut la préparer et par conséquent il
faut en discuter
surtout entre deux pays qui sont parmi
les très gros pot leur émetteur de co2
et il ya là deux autres la chine et
l'inde qui est à eux quatre jeux sont
les plus les plus gros émetteurs de co2
par combustion de carbone par conséquent
il est nécessaire de parler et de
préparer les négociations de glasgow
j'ajouterai que
le messager est particulièrement indiqué
pour tester cette méthode puisque comme
l'a dit votre journaliste john kerry
connaît très bien sergueï lavrov
lorsqu'il était secrétaire d'état
d'obama pendant le deuxième mandat du
président des états unis
eh bien ils se sont fréquemment
rencontrés ils se connaissent par
conséquent très bien et on voit bien qu
il que ce sont de 2,2 fin diplomate
c'est à dire que la méthode qu'ils
appliquent la est une méthode très
souvent utilisé dans la diplomatie dans
les clous mais si on identifie les
sujets sur lesquels on peut progresser
sur lequel on peut se mettre d'accord
et puis on l'espère plus tard des sujets
plus difficiles où même les sujets qui
fâchent
il ya d'ailleurs eu vendredi dernier une
autre expérience dans la matière au
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
tout le monde était très surpris que
russie etats-unis présentent une
résolution conjointe pour maintenir
probablement pour un an le couloir
humanitaire qui permet de maintenir en
vie un certain nombre de personnes dans
la poche d'idlib en syrie on croyait que
la russie s'y opposerait eh bien il ya
une résolution conjointe qui a fait
l'unanimité du conseil de sécurité
quels sont au club blanchemaison pour
sagan il avancé john kerry les réels
enjeux de cet entretien sur le climat le
réel enjeu c'est comme l'on dit tout à
l'heure les deux personnalités qui se
rencontraient à moscou pratiquement tout
le monde est d'accord sur le fait qu'il
faut arriver à la neutralité carbone en
2050 alors 2050 ça paraît facile parce
que c'est loin mais à glasgow
chaque pays participant sera invité à
faire des annonces personnelles prêts à
prendre des engagements des engagements
si frais est également un cheminement
pour arriver à ce résultat
lointain or actuellement les courbes de
2,2 de pollution les courbes l'émission
de co2 ne sont pas très encourageantes
il ya tout lieu de penser qu
actuellement les objectifs que s'était
fixés
la conférence de paris la coop 21 ne
seront pas respectées il faut donc
renforcer les efforts et on sent bien
que dans les milieux politiques dans la
société civile des différents pays
il y à une pression dans ce sens les
villes les régions les grandes
entreprises prennent des décisions dans
ce sens avec ou sans le consentement des
états dans lesquels elles se trouvent
on a bien vu comme monsieur trump est
sortie de l'accord de paris est bien
certain nombre de régions un certain
nombre de villes un certain nombre
d'entreprises ont fait savoir qu'elles
continueraient d'appliquer ses
conclusions et ses résolutions
donc c'est important que de pays comme
la russie et les etats-unis décident
devraient ensemble dans cette
négociation à glasgow le sommet de
genève un on en parlait tout à l'heure
entre vladimir poutine et joe biden
entre ces deux pays ont renforcé leur
coopération vous l'avez expliqué claude
mais toujours rien du côté de leurs
rapports avec la russie pourquoi l'union
européenne s'obstine tel s'obstine tels
faits y arriver à ne pas déléguer avec
la russie question de méthode
en effet le 24 juin le conseil européen
n'a pas pu aboutir à un accord
la france et l'allemagne avaient proposé
de reprendre lé sommet semestriel qui
avait lieu jusqu'à la fin 2013
entre l'union européenne et la russie et
sept états membres s'y sont opposés
alors vous me direz il en reste 20
autres qui étaient d'accord ou qui
pouvaient accepter la réunion n'avait
pas été très bien préparé peut-être
madame merkel aurait dû prendre aurait
pu prendre la tâche d'un certain nombre
d'autres états membres qui sont
favorables à ce dialogue par exemple par
exemple elle signe qui qui aurait
peut-être pu amoindrir les réserves de
la suède par rapport à cet accord peut
être aussi d'autres pays auraient pu
parlez à la pologne et parler aux pays
baltes pour qu'ils ne mettent pas un
veto absolu à la reprise de ces réunions
qui ont encore une fois été très
régulière jusqu'en 2014
alors maintenant il faut prendre la
méthode diplomatique classique
c'est-à-dire identifier des projets des
sujets sur lesquels on peut faire des
progrès qui sont les parce que ce sont
des sujets d'intérêt commun et se réunir
pour en discuter
alors peut-être faut-il différencier les
interlocuteurs peut-être faut-il
différencier aussi le format des
réunions il se trouve que la france a
exercé la présidence du conseil de
l'union européenne au semestre prochain
et rien n'empêche la france en effet
dans cette perspective de prendre des
initiatives et s'il ya un blocage de tel
ou tel pays est bien de faire des
réunions informelles avec les pays qui
le souhaitent pour discuter avec la
russie sur les sujets d'intérêts communs
sur lesquels nous devons aboutir à des
résultats d'ici là de toute manière ils
eurent à glasgow
à la veille de glace d'eau il y aura le
g20 auquel participent l'union
européenne et un certain nombre des plus
grands états membres de l'union
européenne
par conséquent ces sujets seront évoqués
au g20 à la veille de glasgow
merci claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales